I remember uh first time I ever met you
you do no actually I do
no I do it
when you said no that was really fun I
saw you rise up and then fall down no
you came to our apartment and I met you
or was it someone else's no no no yeah
we had worked together on SNL but I
wasn't yeah I was very shy
and I remembered I don't want to get in
Steve so I was writing things but not
approaching you I was in the background
but then uh I was chosen for you know
Lauren said I think this fellow could
host the Late Night show it'll be rough
for a few years but you'll eventually
get it I think he could do it so I'm
named Letterman's replacement and the
first thing I do when I come out to LA
is Lauren says maybe this is a thing he
does but he said let's take a walk
through the flats of Beverly Hills and
people told me later on that Lauren
takes a take a walk and when he's taking
this walk and he's giving me advice he's
saying always tip you're known now
always tip at least 15 or you'll you'll
show up in the post that was I thought
he was going to tell me like here's the
secret yeah but he was telling me things
like that which was fine and then he
said
um let's see if Steve's in and I didn't
know you know Steve he always assumed
Steve Croft and so yeah exactly so uh we
he knocks on a door and you answer and
you'll have us into your place
and I was like this is too much I've
I've just been put into this situation
and I need to
um navigate this and now we're dropping
in on Steve Martin and I'll never forget
you had just had all the paintings
taken down and I think I just said like
oh there are no paintings and you
reacted immediately as if you had been
robbed
what oh my God and I thought oh
that's funny that's a perfect
reaction to where you're painting yeah
whenever whenever in studio a member
wants uh every now and then you'd be in
the studio at 6A rehearsing and the
lights would go out because of some
situation in the building Rockefeller
Center some situation the lights would
just go out and Andy would always
instantly scream my pearls
Andy who Andy Richter oh they're
hilarious yeah it was just my pearls and
uh
oh I gotta remember that funny but I
have to give him credit yeah no you
don't no you don't no just take it no no
Andy was fine I know I'll blow it my
purpose
reviews I mean pearls my Pez my Pez how
did you guys decide we're going to start
working together as a as two-hander a
two-hander act uh what did that come
about I'll tell you what
uh it's a boring story so I'm gonna give
it to you no no it was 2011 we were
asked to interview each other for it was
the closing the just for last Comedy
Festival in Chicago it was May
and it was 2011 and we just entered what
do we have for breakfast I guess you had
scrambled eggs I had french toast ah
come on man I had syrup no and we
interviewed each other and that was it
and and it went well and we thought we'd
do it again and we just then well the
the funny part is we were interviewing
each other about comedy for a Comedy
Festival right so we could talk about
comedy kind of like we're doing here but
you know two comedy people it's kind of
interesting so we thought hey let's do
that again so we got a corporate gig or
something for dentists and so we're
sitting and we're talking about comedy
and we're thinking this doesn't work
yeah and then we started and Marty had a
show he did uh solo and I had a show
that I did with a band and so we kind of
combined them but he had material and I
had a bunch of songs with funny intros
and when we first when we first started
working together he he had everything
and I kind of had nothing and because I
didn't bring the band I said well I got
to bring the band so that's when it
started to gel into a show and I can go
on yeah no no yeah and I can go on no no
it's it's it's first of all that was
great well as I was saying
I was saying that no I think you said it
oh really yeah you know this is just but
I didn't think I got to the party oh you
didn't need to okay this reminds me of I
made the mistake once uh it's and you
know it it's like wearing the shorts but
I knew I I I made this terrible mistake
of someone had mentioned food and what
they eat and I said well you know what I
do now is I eat two meals a day I have
like a shake at 11 and I put a lot of
spinach in it and then I try to eat
dinner early like at five
and then I as I'm finishing saying it I
see Marty just staring at me the way the
way a shark looks like it looks at a
canned ham that fell into the ocean and
he looks at me and he said you know when
other people discuss the details of
their diet it's boring but not you
and of course there were some writers
standing around who were like yes well
they love when the boss is attacked that
was also just me realizing I
why did I get into this why did I lather
myself up with bacon grease and then
climb into this piranha pool why did I
why did I do my wife has a very wise
about about talking about what you eat
she said you're allowed to talk about
what you do eat but you're not allowed
to talk about what you do very good
that's very good oh that's good I like
that yeah I like that I mean if this
podcast if we go away with one thing
that's it it's like with me beats I
don't
I think it's uh I mean I'm curious one
thing I was curious about is do you when
you come up with a great new insult
for the other do you ever try it out in
the Moment On Stage or do you ever have
you tried to surprise each other uh not
really but sometimes we've come up with
things and then we'll go right to the
prompter afterwards and say oh right
that you know we'll remember what what
prompt her that if we had a problem we
had to say if we had a prompter yeah so
you're saying if we had a problem yeah
we would come up with a joke we would go
over and talk I know I mean now we just
go to our own minds and lock it in